[Music]
hi i'm susie annetta founding
editor-in-chief of design anthology and
i'm excited to be curating the emerge
showcase at find design fare as part of
singapore design week 2022 the first of
its kind showcase of the region emerge
at find will present an assembly of new
work from designers from across south
east asia from 60 plus designers that
are recent graduates to those emerging
and more established names
the intention is to create an engaging
showcase of work from the region unlike
anything that's been seen before in
terms of scale and diversity amongst the
list of talented designers that we've
brought together there's a number of
emerging talents to keep an eye on kong
dao is a young furniture designer who's
never shown her work outside of vietnam
before she's passionate about
environmental sustainability and
ensuring that her work doesn't create
more waste
for indonesia we have denny prieta who
enjoys challenging conventions and
modernising traditional processes
denny will be showcasing a hand-carved
chair and table set which draw on local
traditional hand carving skills and to
complement those a set of accessories
which are actually produced from the
scraps and leftovers that come from the
production of the chair and table
and finally cynthia chan a recent
graduate of national university of
singapore's design incubation program
cynthia's approach is quite experimental
and she likes to raise questions with
her work rather than draw conclusions at
emerge cynthia will be presenting a
collection of rugs made from dog hair
that has been salvaged from dog grooming
parlors
come find us at singapore design week
[Music]